hello and welcome to learning about it
with me Lulu today we're going to be
learning about interference interference
is when a player blocks the line of an
opponent's piece from the square root of
Defense by putting his own piece or the
opponent's piece in the way
so here it's black to play what's a good
interfering move it's F for blocking the
Queen from defending the bishop the
Queen can't take this pawn and keep
defending the bishop because there's a
pawn defending there so now pawn takes
and Bishop takes winning the bishop
because White's own pawn here blocks the
Queen from defending here's another
example it's black to play what's the
interfering move Bishop d4 check
blocking the rook from defending the
Queen the rook has to take to keep
defending the Queen and now the pawn can
take with check so we win a queen so to
recap today we learned right
interference interference is a good idea
if you're thinking about taking a piece
but it's defended so thanks for learning
about it with me Lulu and make sure to
LIKE and subscribe Wow